salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point en particulier du cerveau dans les
épisodes précédents vous avez proposé de
parler des super pouvoirs de notre
cerveau et de notre corps c'est le sujet
du jour
bienvenue dans matière crise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre
quatre expériences expérience une
remonte dans la douleur et à
l'expérience deux pas radi expérience 3
c'est à vous expérience 4 la bêta 8
jambes
le tout avec la présence très appréciée
de juju fidh casse
alors oui notre cerveau est capable de
faire des choses incroyables notre camp
aussi et on grâce à un peu plus loin
dans l'émission notre capacité de calcul
par exemple semble limité semble
pourtant on estime la capacité de
stockage de notre cerveau à 2,5
pétaoctets soit 2500 téraoctets le
superordinateur cas qui comporte quand
même 86000 processeurs a mis 40 minutes
à essayer de reproduire une seconde
d'activité de notre cerveau nous serions
nous capables de faire nuit milliards de
milliards d'opérations par seconde
pourtant quand tout le monde de calcul
et 12 soit 13 ans de galère pour
utiliser pleinement nos supers pouvoirs
il faut des astuces des modes d'emploi
par exemple dans quelques minutes vous
et juju fit quatre serait capable de
savoir quel jour de la semaine
ton n'importe quelle date de l'année en
quelques secondes à peine
bien oui mais super pouvoirs ça serait
génial mais en fait on a déjà dans sa
tête et dans son corps si vous regardez
où tu vas tu montes tu shootes way la
messe est violent dangereux
c'est comme ça je vais t'apprendre à
faire un truc qui te paraît pas possible
et qui vous paraît pas possible vous
aurez le verra aussi après c'est je te
dis n'importe quelle date et tu dis
ouais ok c'est un mardi
ouais c'est un jeudi ouais c'est un
vendredi c'est à dire de reconnaître
n'importe quel jour de la semaine
ah ouais de cette année ou l'année
prochaine c'est pas très dur pour ça il
faut deux choses il faut connaître un
chiffre par coeur c'est lui
alors ouais pour pâques t elle connaître
par coeur dès aujourd'hui on va garder
le panneau et il faut connaître sa table
de cette es là tu la vois temps ça fait
toujours recette de poisson 14 3 x 7 21
4 x 7 28 top parce qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de ça en fait il ya juste besoin
du début de la table de 7
ok tu vois c'est pas grand chose et
pourquoi le début de la table de cette
parce que dans une semaine ya sept jours
donc forcément si je suis
lundi 1er janvier est bien celle jours
plus tard je serai encore un lundi parce
que c'était un 8 hockey et sept jours
plus tard je serai encore lundi et c'est
donc c'est basé là dessus
est ce que de l'ajustement il renferme
le premier lundi de chaque mois
c'est pour ça que tu as deux chiffres le
premier lundi de janvier
c'est un 400m janvier mai de cette année
de cette année adacore ouais non ça
c'est le code pin de 2021 ça c'est le
premier lundi de février c'est 1er
février et le 1er mars et hamadi le 5
avril est un lundi et c'est jusqu'au 6
décembre qui est le premier lundi de
décembre
si tu veux le faire pour l'année
prochaine et bien faire mais il suffit
de faire moins un ok tu vois doute là il
ya un calendrier ne le regarde pas t'as
pas tenir sa part ça c'est à l'envers et
on va faire un test très simple c'est
toi qui vas me tester pour l'instant je
vais te voir comment ça marche tu me dis
n'importe quelle date
maintenant comme ça le 12 décembre le 12
décembre
ok le 12 décembre je sais exactement que
c'est un dimanche on va vérifier
décembre 12 décembre
c'est un 10 mis d'accord début j'ai vu
l'annoncé
ok alors pourquoi je les trouvais
simplement parce que dans ma tête
moi je le connais par coeur le code je
sais pas que le premier lundi des 506
j'ai fait 6 + 7
ça fait treize donc j'ai su que le 13
décembre c'était un lundi
tu vois j'ai cherché le deuxième lundi
le plus proche de ta date tu vois ce que
je veux dire donc j'ai fait 6 et 7 ça
fait treize et après je tâtonne comme un
enfant je me suis donc lundi 13 de même
si je reviendrais hier c'est dimanche 12
ce qui veut dire que si ça avait été
plus loin dans le moi tu aurais
peut-être pris plus tôt le 2 x 7 ou 8
exactement
voici tu m'avais dit par exemple le 24
décembre
tout simplement je me serais dit ok donc
le 6 décembre saint anne à 10 14 et si
ça fait vingt donc je sais qu'on est à
lundi 20 donc moi je me dis mardi 21
mercredi 22 jeudi 23 vendredi 24 c'est
un vendredi et elle doit après que tu
termines en tâtonnant un petit peu tu
cherches à te rapprocher plus de la date
et après tu trouves et le coach je le
connais par coeur parce que le cerveau
mais maurice très bien les choses par
paquets comme ça ok donc entendu le fait
que tu écris par trois mois exactement
et puis c'est plus simple dans ma tête
si tu me dis par exemple juillet eh bien
je sais que c'est lui
tu vois je sais qu'il y en a eu six
avance assez bien le septième mois c'est
plus simple à visualiser quand même si
vous voulez la prendre c'est plus simple
de visualiser maintenant on va essayer
avec toi en plus tard
attention se cache un papier ça faisait
prendre un peu de temps
le 14 juillet s'il vous plaît alors 14
juillet du coup je sais que le premier
lundi du mois de juillet c'est le 5
oui donc je vais faire juste avec le set
parce que du coup sept jours plus tard
c'est le dit non non non tu rajoutes
trace un pari à temps en temps ça fait
12 ce qui fait que c'est le lundi 12
petites bêtises et tu m'as demandé le 14
juillet
mercredi 14 oct on vérifie juillet 14
juillet oui c'est trop bien ou pas
c'était pas trop là ça va non kate et on
croit que j'ai fait en 30 secondes tu
dois faire ma dignité dernière fois
attention nouvelle date
les 4 février cette passion universelle
tu crois que c'est au hasard c'est un
papier rose février mais attendait
justement rappelé en quelques jours cité
mais je me rebelle déjà [ __ ] je dis ok
19 janvier avec c'était un dimanche
c'était quoi si daniel thibault aouita
musée beaubourg qu'il faut des papiers
je vais tous les envoyer là pas mal pas
mal de noms mais chic ça c'est
incroyable
attention sur les paupières rose que ça
me fait rire est née l'idée d'être clés
à sa semaine d'après mais c'est pas
grave le 1er avril s'il vous plaît alors
avril du coup ces cas viennent donc on
sait que le lundi c'était le 5
c'est ça ouais ok donc lundi 5 voilà je
fais du coup dimanche 3 samedi 2
vendredi 1er avril 2003 ah non dimanche
4 1 ce dimanche skate samedi 3 vendredi
de jeudi je vérifie oui mais lui c'était
bien parce que je voulais l'essayer
parce que ça te fait partir en arrière
et oui ça me suffit amplement à un petit
dernier pour ces sétois qui pioche ce
que tu veux 31 mai à temps mais c'est un
lundi pour trois mois en fût donc lundi
3 mai donc on a dit ah ben je peux faire
avec la table directe de cette fois cat
way cette fois 4,28
j'ajoute 28 ans tout va bien maintenant
il part tout ce que tu as dit juste en
dessous des 3 plus souvent dit a fait 31
oui ok donc je sais mais est-ce que ça
ça veut dire que je sais que c'est le
lundi 31 à ouvrir ce que je qualifie
quand même parce que je oui on aurait
même pu faire pire c'est à dire que
puisque je sais que le 7 juin c'est
mandy une semaine avant on était le 31
mai ah ouais
facile bravo à ces trois gars parce que
t'as pas un nouveau super non mais grave
mais je vais vous la péter ça je le
prendre en photo
oui c'est ça ou vous parker ou tu le
gardes avec toi il vise à valider
pouvoir valider vous vous rendez compte
en retenant juste cette série de
chiffres et le début de la table de
cette vous pouvez déduire n'importe quel
jour de la semaine de cette année ou
même de l'année prochaine ou l'année
d'avant en fait il suffit de faire moins
ou plus 1 sur le jour du mois mais il
n'ya pas que votre cerveau qui a des
super pouvoirs ou vos cinq sens sont
presque des super-pouvoirs à part
entière et on va voir ça maintenant
alors cette fois ci ça change un peu
parce que cette vidéo est sponsorisé par
oi encore toujours
excuse moi tu aurais pas une version
italienne de votre temps est infinie tu
sais pas encore excuse moi on aurait pas
une version chinoise de votre cerveau et
extraordinaire de métier tout les
inventeurs excuse moi on ne devrait pas
une version tchèque cours pour checker
si c'est bien calée pour que l'état
table bah oui mais la chanteuse emmerder
mon manque un tout on écrira en fait que
je puisse qu'aller ma table excuse-moi
juridique mais je me sens un peu
manipulée par le fait que tu veuilles
que j'écrive un livre pour quelle est ta
table mais après est un ami donc ça
tombe bien parce que là ce mois ci au
mois de mai je sort un nouveau livre
c'est quoi j'arrive à l'antique draine
manipulation et après je peux mettre un
petit dossier à l'afld encore comment
câline table avec mêlée donc oui c'est
vrai j'ai écrit un nouveau livre qui
sort le 12 mai qui s'appelle lentilles
guide de la manipulation en fait ils
vivent de manipulation j'aurais aimé
ht/mois ya des années ça ça va parler de
la manipulation bienveillante la
manipulation honnête la mauvaise
manipulation
comment s'en défendre il ya des vrais
exemples concrets sur des cas quotidiens
sur du marketing sur de la politique
vous avez le lien pour le commander dans
la description le précommander j'espère
que ça vous plaira
ça peut servir à plein de choses excuse
moi et cela est ce que tu peux l'écrire
un peu plus épais que les autres pour
que je puisse bien qu'elle est là bas tu
nous donnes le cm qui te manquer puis
j'écrirai plus pour le logo
un doigt ok un doigt il y as naissance
que vous connaissez bien la vue l'ouïe
le toucher par exemple on les a exploré
dans le 2ème matière grise que je vous
invite à voir le lien dans la
description
néanmoins dans l'essence principaux nous
n'avons pas vraiment abordé le goût et
l'odorat notre langue est un organe
incroyable qui possède plus de 3000
papilles ses papilles détecte le sucré
l'amer le salé l'acide et c'est tout
alors comment on peut sentir les autres
saveurs eh bien on va voir ça avec jeux
et vous pourrez en plus leur faire chez
vous faut pas grand-chose
tu me vois bien normal genevois a
seulement rien j'ai l'impression d'avoir
un soutien gorge sur lisieux
c'est vraiment ça on y soutient top
alors aujourd'hui on va travailler sur
un sens oublier c'est jeu doha et
bizarrement on va faire ça en montrant à
quel point il est important pour le loup
est donc toi tu cuisines et normalement
ça m'intéressait de le faire tester à
toi parce que le goût en fait en réalité
notre langue nos papilles de 3000 papy
sur la langue elle détecte l'acide
l'amer le sucré le salé c'est tout
toutes les autres saveurs
ça passe par le nez en réalité et du
coup on va voir si on te privant de la
vue et de l'odorat grâce à un magnifique
passe ni qu'on va la totale quoi
si tu arrives à différencier des
aliments les uns contre les autres petit
spoil il n'y a aucun aliment chez nous
il ya un blizzard n'y a rien que tu ne
manges pas déjà dans ton quotidien
est-ce que c'est des trucs fait ou pas
non ok tebib où tu valides 1b vous à la
validation
tout va bien ok il ya promis à rien de
ce look hockey ah oui de passe n'est
bien sûr je te confie je te laisse le
maître par contre t'as déjà vu débarquer
à ces affreux ok là j'ai une cuillère de
la cuillère il ya un petit truc à manger
il reste qu'un seul trou au niveau du
visage tu peux pas t'en sais quoi ça tu
verras mais c'est un truc que tu marches
déjà tout va bien ah ouais tout
jure que c'est vrai c'est foutu mesure
c'est normal attention sur super
seulement promu nord est ce que c'est un
sucre et du café
alors oui déjà c'est incroyable de voir
que quand on supprime c'est du sucre
c'est du sucre alors il ya du sucre
c'est quelque chose de sucré
effectivement et comme je disais les
papilles des pelles de fruits manger dix
mois après boom pow oui ok pain
au début je pensais que c'était un bout
de sucre trempé dans du café rien à voir
et à vivre est une petite patte de voix
il a imploré
c'est très dur de parler de respirer
avec un c'est que je transfère l'accueil
du show attendant on va vite en chine et
inquiète mais ok c'est fou là pas du
tout du goût du hip hop je mange
habituellement ça c'est normal
elle a presque pas debout en fait en
fait il ya que le sucre est que tu sens
très très bien et comme t'as pas le
retour à l'arrière qui rompt par le net
ap alassane est encore tu sens le sucré
mais c'est pas autant que d'habitude tu
vois passion c'est ici à peu près d'eux
pour fort boyard à sa red bull à
c'est un pas de goût là l'eau de coco
alors en fait le problème de ce que tu
manges sais que c'est pas acide c'est
pas amer c'est pas sucré c'est pas salé
du coup tu as l'impression c'est à
padoue ouais ça à zéro ou là dans ma
bouche enlève ton pince nez en azote en
amérique si c'est dur a dit tu peux tu
pas au bal masqué la section s'est vu de
suite en vrai c'est ton de doral super
pouvoirs on est capable de capter des
milliers des milliers de saveur
différente parce qu'on a un très bon
odorat
contrairement d'ailleurs à l'idée reçue
qui dit que les animaux ont un meilleur
doraat nous on a autant ne pas l'être
c'est juste qu'on ne sent pas les mêmes
choses
c'est surtout ça qui importe est que si
tu couple doha en fait on goût c'est un
pouvoir très très limité cinq sens très
limité le même si ruf genre dès que j'ai
enlevé mes vraiment l'impression de
manger nous avons tous besoin tu sais de
fin j'avais déjà le bout qui venait même
sont reprochés un nouveau morceau gens
le goût est tout de suite arriver c'est
ouais et je vous invite chez vous
vraiment prenez aussi du radis et
bouchez vous les aimez manger le essayer
de plus vrai d'analyser le truc ou
faites le sur quelqu'un qui sait pas
pareil vous voulez demander de jouer le
jeu de cacher les yeux et de se pincer
le nez et vous lui fait manger un
morceau de radis et c'est juste par
contre évidemment si la personne vous
fait confiance je compte sur vous pour
faire faire manger des trucs cool et
boire d'être cool parce qu'on valide le
fait que le dorat c'est un super
pouvoirs et bien sûr mais ça c'est un
truc de fou mais ça pour le coup je le
sais parce que je l'avais étudié que
j'avais fait tout un j'avais suivi toute
un cours sur tout ce qui était système
olfactif et c est en fait c'est
impressionnant oui de voir que tout est
complètement relié à l'intérieur
appartenons tu perds l'odorat le goût
c'est strictement rien à voir mais c'est
pour ça que quand on est malade il ya
plein de trucs on sent plus et quand on
mange on est en mode
super fade oui que la perte de l'odorat
c'est toujours un signe qu'il faut aller
consulter c'est anormal
la perte d'un sens c'est anormal si toi
tu en moins bien tu vas consulter si tu
vois moins bien tu vas consultait assez
bizarrement quelqu'un qui sent un peu
moins et comment une cousine hand ça va
ça va passer c'est toujours un signal du
corps important pour se dire et
maintenant j'ai plus sentie plus de goût
j'avais 8 ans ok vous avez compris tout
ce passe grâce à l'odorat depuis le 19e
siècle une idée reçue dit que l'être
humain à ne devra plus faible que les
autres animaux
mais les études de john nack gagnent de
l'université du new-jersey montre que
l'être humain peut différencier des
milliers et des milliers d'auteurs
différentes mais forcément là où un
chien va plus facilement sortir des
informations dans l'uriné par exemple
l'être humain n'y va plus facilement
détailler les effluves de fruité d'un
vin alors oui notre doha est clairement
un super pouvoirs et notre corps aussi
d'ailleurs
ça vous le verrez tout à l'heure nous
allons maintenant voir des choses
incroyables fait par des êtres humains
qui n'avait rien de particulier au
départ par rapport à vous et moi
mais attention certaines des choses que
je veux dire seront vrai et d'autres
seront fausses et ce sera veut faire la
différence chez vous et dans les
commentaires je joue et vous aussi
c'est le moment du c'est à vous en gros
je te pose des questions habituellement
il faut me donner une réponse et vous
donne la réponse dans les commentaires
là c'est un peu différent
je vais te faire des affirmations sur
des choses et tu verras si c'est vrai ou
faux sauf le dernier c'est vraiment une
question du coup tu laisses une main
dure année rares pas forcément c'est des
faits divers sur des super pouvoirs qui
ont eu des personnes il faut savoir si
c'est vrai ou pas vrai est ce que c'est
moi qui ai inventé le truc où est-ce que
ça a vraiment existé première un garçon
de 13 ans sauf deux personnes de la
noyade dont une qui avait un saut de
pierres autour du cou je pense que c'est
vrai ce possible parce que vous pensez
que c'est vrai
oui j'en crois que c'est quoi si c'est
vrai c'était dans le var d'ailleurs et
c'est un jeune garçon de 13 ans qui
faisait du paddle et il a vu en fait
quelqu'un qui semblait se noyer en fait
c'est quelqu'un qui essaie une médecin
séjour doute le fait qu'il s'était
attaché un saut de pierres et il a sauvé
il allait nager la récupère et demi sur
le paddle a ramené il a vu qu'il ya
quelqu'un de piste noyer il l'a récupéré
il a sauvé des deux essais juste
incroyable de voir à quel point un
moment donné la détermination c'est ça
fout ouais incroyable bravo tu as une
fois en l'espèce humaine vertement
deuxième affirmation fait divers une
femme de 19 ans soulève une voiture
d'une tonne à manu pour sauver son père
alors je sais que c'est possible que ce
sera tout à fait possible parce que
quand il se passe un truc qui touche à
tes proches
ta famille tes amis vraiment projet car
il se passe quelque chose dans ton corps
qui fait que tu es capable de faire un
truc un peu sur humains et nous
typiquement on dépend on fait des vidéos
sur youtube ou avec des strongman c'est
des gens qui soulève des poids
impressionnant et en fait qui disent que
pour soulever ces pâles elle se met dans
des conditions où en fait s'il imagine
que ont tu leurs femmes par exemple donc
qu'il pense vraiment avait tout hyper
horrible je vous dis là en l'occurrence
c'est vraiment un truc horrible qui
arrive
j'ai envie de dire que c'est vrai ok par
contre ce que tu dis c'est génial je
savais pas qu'ils utilisaient cette
méthode là parce que en gros oui quand
en fait il ya la force absolue la force
maximale et la farce absolue et du coup
on sait que quand on a de l'adrénaline
dans le sang on atteint sa pleine
capacité de force quitte par contre
smoothies ya évidemment mais on peut
faire des choses dingues
donc c'est hyper intéressant de savoir
qu'il se mette dans ces conditions
cérébrale avoir un coût c'est vrai c'est
complètement bourré cette jeune fille
elle faisait à m 68 pour 59 kg le
véhicule était en feu il y avait son
père en dessous c'était dans le garage
elle a réussi à soulever la voiture donc
qu'ils aient une tonne pour que son père
se dégage troisième anecdote en 2017
un enfant de deux ans soulève un meuble
pour sauver son frère jumeau d'un côté
jean
dire que c'est vrai d'un autre je me dis
ça fait déjà deux fois qu'on havrais là
tu vas je fais une autre ce matin je me
dis normalement aimerait bien qu'ils
aient un peu de poids un moment mais à
tout moment tu peux juste avoir décidé
de mettre tous en vrai j'ai envie de
dire qu'à deux ans tu te rends pas
forcément compte de ce qui se passe donc
gérer fou alors c'est vrai et il ya une
caméra de surveillance car enregistrait
sa donc au début tu vois l'enfant en
fait donc tu vois son frère qui se le
même nombre de suisses pointent cetc il
suffoque
tu vois que son frère jumeau il regarde
et il est châtain ces jeux pas de
problème
jouer jouer à un moment donné tu voyais
lhc joue et quand même il vas voir tu
vois qui comprend pas ce qui se passe
mais il ya un truc quand même dans la
survie qui est un peu bizarre
et là il soulève un meuble qui est un
peu fou quoi tu vois a soulevé est
pareil et son frère se dégage de lui
même du coup là les parents arrive pile
poil à ce moment là donc c'est même pas
lui après qu'il repose nommé tout ça
donc dès le plus jeune âge là on peut
accéder aux quais bas tu veux ça que
c'était la question je demanderai cts
qu' il n'y a pas une limite entre
guillemets est-ce que déjà d un ou deux
ans tu peux avoir ce cette pensée de se
dire il est en train d'arriver quelque
chose à quelqu'un des actifs si jeune
4e un alsacien a retenu près de
quasiment 2000 chiffres en 30 minutes
je pense que c'est vrai je pense que
c'est possible 2000 chiffres en 30
minutes parker bas au vu de ce que je
vois être et confort de lecture de la
vitesse à laquelle les gens bizarres iv
répondent aux questions après que sont
posées je me dis il ya forcément
quelqu'un dans le monde qui peut retenir
autant de chiffres un super temps
absolument et c'est le record du monde
1995 chiffres en 30 minutes donc il ya
des concours comme ça de mémoire la
règle des astuces évidemment pour bien
utiliser sa mémoire
il n'a pas une meilleure mémoire que les
autres nick de moigné que toi c'est
juste du nil entre elles comme les
scores plus tu entraînes et
et plus tu es meilleur et surtout
l'utilisent les bonnes astuces de
mémorisation et donc il a été capable de
faire ça et moi je me dis ok ça c'est
pas tous ces cas là qu'on voit la d44
convient de voir c'est des choses qu'on
fait pas dans notre quotidien mais on a
tous ce super pouvoirs là si on voulait
le faire ne pas assimiler masse quantité
de données d'un pneu peut soulever une
tonne d'un coup si c'était nécessaire il
a bien ses super pouvoirs en nous
dernière question la scène question il
ya que du vrai du coup je me suis planté
une c4 mais ses ouailles avec un duo est
ce que tu connais le record du 100 m
passé un peu moins de 10 secondes 9
chaînes bolt en 2009
et du coup ma question c'est est-ce
kimba le draw matin le dromadaire ou le
guépard au 100 m un piège une pièce non
c'est vrai d'un côté en tête là je
dirais que le guépard c'est beaucoup
plus rapide qu un dromadaire
en tout cas je pense et en même temps je
pense que si les dromadaires décide de
courir un peu comme des rhinocéros et je
suis sûr qu'en vrai c'est pas parce que
c'est lourd que ça court pas vite du
dromadaire
et ouais c'est plutôt du dromadaire que
ça se rapproche a déjà des dromadaires
court plus vite que ce qu'on pense
objectivement mais par contre ça montre
que notre limite même si on est descendu
en dessous de la barre des 10 secondes
pour faire des 100 m etc n'est plus en
plus performants on n'est pas par contre
équipés pour concours et on va dire avec
des animations fallait pour nous faire
le 100 m parce qu'en fait tous ces
animaux chasseurs là leur but c'est pas
de courir longtemps c'est de courir très
vite pas longtemps pour attraper leurs
proies
donc en fait c'est des machines de
guerre de ça et donc là c'est notre
seule limite dans les super pouvoirs
c'est que notre corps il pourra pas
faire des actions dont on a pas eu
besoin depuis le début de l'humanité
d'actu voit on est on a des super
pouvoirs entre guillemets pour faire des
trucs de force ou de choses comme ça
dont on avait besoin
mais quand on n'a jamais eu besoin de
courir après des goûts pour les attraper
les manger on pourra jamais à 200 mètres
en 2 secondes c'était pour faire voir sa
maison madère court 8
mais oui les gens syndrome cher attend
une pourquoi abbas à ses dromadaires
alors que le chameau ces charmants exact
wiimote et du coup je me suis toujours
dit quand j'étais enfant c'était voilà
justement mais aussi le chameau ces 2
bat dromadaires ch désolé ça devrait
porter plainte rôle responsable de la
mnémotechnique non mais je suis d'accord
aurait dû trouver un autre nom sinon
aussi le fédéral et c'est un super
pouvoir humain et c'est la mémoire est
un super pouvoir français bon pour la
dernière expérience va avoir besoin de
ton corps et du corps d'un peu tout le
monde et aussi de thibault ok c'est pas
mal ça paie les tournages c'est pas pour
youtube vous expliquer parmi ses
exploits il faut noter que ces personnes
n'ont pas plus de prédisposition que
vous ou moi au départ seulement un
entraînement particulier pour usain bolt
nous avons tous des ressources
insoupçonnées et même la science peine
parfois à expliquer des exploits
physiques
probablement grâce à des poussées
d'adrénaline le kinésiologue américain
vladimir sachs qui vous lisez le lion
valdes est clair c'est mieux explique
qu'il existe deux sortes de puissance
physique la force maximale et la force
absolue c'est à dire la puissance que
l'on peut avoir par notre volonté est la
deuxième étant la limite de puissance
qu'on peut développer la force maximale
vaut environ 65 % de notre force absolue
en moyenne voyons ce qu'on pourrait
faire aujourd'hui avec notre corps
nous allons terminer en soumettant juin
tests de résistance physique avec
thibault mais aussi avec deux autres
personnes de l'équipe qui dut ne sont
pas entraînés et de deux ne sont pas
prévenus qu'on allait faire ça est-ce
que leur corps arriveront à relever le
même exploit physique on va voir ça tout
de suite
pour cette dernière expérience avec juju
j'ai été rejoint par thibaut yes cd rom
mais par famille il ya le hic aussi
qu'il va nous rejoindre parce qu'on va
avoir besoin d'un chef opérateur est le
chien le super pouvoir qu'on développe
là qu'on prouve là c'est là notre
capacité à résister notre capacité
corporelle a résisté à plein de choses
vous connaissez les corps mieux que moi
et on va faire un truc que vous
connaissez peut-être ça se fait dans les
mariages les trucs comme ça j'avais
envie qu'on expérimente nous c'est une
chaise musicale c'est au contraire de
s'asseoir tout sur une chaise d'enlever
les chaises de tenir sanchez mais de
tenir quand même mais je connais quand
on s'assoit lisant sur les autres mais
pas tout ça c'est ouais on va s'asseoir
les uns sur les autres
exactement alors pour faire ça il va
falloir que tout le monde se tourne dans
le même sens c'est à dire tu vas regardé
par là thibault tu vas t'asseoir dans ce
sens là exactement comme ça pour juju et
moi comme ça
loïc est notre chef 16 ouais l'idée
c'est de vérifier que les épaules tombe
bien sur les genoux de l'autre a dit ça
il faut que les web
les épaules sont bien sûr les jambes
c'est pas mal ok je te fais bien aller
tu peux enlever ma chaise maintenant ok
ok famille habite à mais c'est moi qui
ouvre sur les écrans on doit prouver
qu'on rassure tout va bien changer cette
chaîne dont je vous le dis on tourne
vers la droite
allez c'est bon je pense qu'on peut se
laisser tomber on a bientôt l amant de
112 euros
[Applaudissements]
mission réussie donc trouvées là rien
que cette chaîne pas en quoi ce truc
non je veux juste montrer qu'en vrai il
ya des choses avec notre corps qui nous
paraissent impossibles sur et vous vous
démontrer en permanence que tout le
monde en fait peut faire des choses avec
six records donc on a tous un super
corps comme moi j'aime bien dire qu'on a
un super cerveau et que même ce truc qui
paraît improbable où en gros tafani et
moi on n'est pas taillée comme vous lui
sur les jambes tu vois que peu importe
notre note heino torpillant et tout
après on a quand même des capacités à
résister on a quand même des muscs et
après on peut améliorer ça avec des
entraînements communs donc c'était un
peu le message de fin de vidéo est ce
que tu as vu plus que ton cerveau comme
dans ce but les entraînements c'est à
dire que nous chaque jour on passe une
heure trente et deux heures à
s'entraîner presque tous les jours tu vu
ce que tout ça vaut comme ça alors non
parce qu'il n'ya pas un truc qui est
fait volontairement
ok mais par contre
oui je vais être attiré par le fait de
résoudre une énigme
me de monter un projet ou faut calculer
des trucs de lire pas mal de bouquins je
vais être attiré par ça parce que c'est
ma passion comme vous la passion c'est
la salle tu vois que tu as sur le site
et quel ton ça ouais ok en fait je vais
vite m'ennuyer par exemple le soir
si j'ai l'occasion de faire un jeu de
société avec quelqu'un je préférerai
toujours ça à regarder un film jeu un
peu de réflexion et tout ça je vais
travailler je suis chaud et au bureau en
fin de journée dès qu'on allocations ont
fait des jeux de société tous ensemble
et où cette vidéo merci à tous les
participants à toute l'équipe à fannie
et jérémie à la production à loïc à la
réalisation avec toute son équipe les
noms sont dans la description et bien
sûr à jules-fil 4 n'hésitez pas à
découvrir ces vidéos le lien est
également dans la description vous
pouvez partager cette vidéo lalique et
vous abonner c'est gratuit et si cette
série vous plaît vous avez également
tous les anciens épisodes dans la
description alors pouvons nous
développer nos supers pouvoirs sommes
nous des êtres humains qui soudent
exploitons notre propre potentiel
pouvons-nous tous trouvé une voiture par
notre simple volonté nous verrons tout
cela et bien plus dans les prochains
épisodes de matière grise
à très bientôt ciao